fort le gars je vais vous raconter une
rigolade parce que je vous la raconte en
français et je vais le raconter à eux
aussi je racontais j'étais en coulisses
il ya deux minutes je raconte tout c'est
sûr et y'a rien m il ya un mec qui me
fait votre manager ayant ma nature il
m'a un peu poussé comme ça pour regarder
l'écran ça vient de se passer la logar
on raconte toujours accrue tout est ce
qu on peut l'appeler est ce qu'on peut
l'année on adore val à l'horizon
[Applaudissements]
en fait je vous raconte j'étais devant
l'écran et je sens humain qui veut il
faut pas et je les vois pas je sens une
main qui me pousse et de l'écran donc je
me retourne je dis indie iam iam de
managers généraux est donc lâché mais je
te lis j'ai eu un petit coup de pression
enfin vous dire la vérité j'ai failli me
pète avec lui non elle souhaitait la
vérité voilà je suis dit que nos moyens
iam de bosses ok donc tu me pousse pas
donne push me et non qu'après il a
compris c'est mechal mais j'ai failli
nous met une tête doit bien que moi mais
surtout maintenant ça c'est le sas et la
lega bout raconte c'est toujours ça n'a
l'air d'aimer ça chez nous maintenant je
le kiffe
on est comme ça ou herbe comme l'ail
tango une cache d hyper fin coup